thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a vibrant
wild ride with Stevo we've got Benny
Blanca man and you're going to hear me
say this very close to the top my
favorite guest in a long time he's just
got that Vibe man that Energy's laid
back and like the second we started I
was just loving him he's uh insanely
wealthy unbelievably successful and uh
man does he rub elbows with incredibly
famous people all of the time it was an
honor to speak with Benny Blanco and
you're gonna love it so let's get into
it I like oh you got a [__] in here
too yeah
[Music]
number one rule you know they've changed
since you've been on tour right you know
you can shoot it on tour bus yes the
last guy I said oh yeah I haven't been
the last guy
I was just my brains out all across
America like two weeks ago really oh
yeah incredible because even the guy
Bobby who had uh you know sometimes we
uh start off like earlier than the intro
and I think we're gonna keep this okay
ladies and gentlemen
oh we're rolling hey guys
ladies and gentlemen Benny Blanco hey
guys yeah so you're shooting All Over
America yeah
you know this is so great I don't really
uh I don't fly really I like I don't do
we hate airplane no no no you don't
understand I take a boat when I go to
Europe like I take an actual boat and
and you you don't start here you have to
drive to New York and then once you get
to New York then you get on a boat for
seven and a half days and then after the
seven and a half days you have to drive
to London you're like land like
somewhere you don't even know where the
[__] you are oh your coffee's done you
don't even know yeah [__] what's that
like being on a boat for seven and a
half days what do you do the whole time
oh my God what don't you do okay okay
okay I'll tell you I'll tell you what I
do I don't like to be you're really on
the Titanic you're on the actual Titan
you're on the thing called the Queen
Mary too so it's like the Titanic you
get on for some reason I'm not scared of
those so you get on
and I'm not scared of anything except
flying in my life I'm not scared of
heights either I love roller coasters
snakes don't care nothing I'm not scared
of any like I don't care if a cockroach
crawls in my mouth right now did you
just have a bad experience flying once
you had like a bad experience was like
right when I started like to to like
make money and then like I had a
experience and then I flew a few more
times after and I like got spooked and
then I was like ah maybe one of my I was
on tour with friends and I was like oh
[__] why don't I just
take this thing across the country and
then I did and then you know you're in
your head and ooh that was a good bro
you're in your head when you say this
thing you made a tour bus yeah a tour
bus a tour bus so then so then I just
started doing it at first we actually
weren't riding tour buses we were riding
like she like like fours and stuff no
not even like and then they like moved
up and then it was like a tour bus I was
on tour one time and I was like why am I
not taking a tour bus took a tour bus
and then like uh it just got in my own
head about the
but you the on the boat okay boat is
like
you and old people it's just you and
like thousands of old people like half
the people will die well by the time you
get there
it's crazy
see you're talking to me it's like a
cruise ship yeah it's like the ultimate
cruise ship like the rich people like
they wear suits to I couldn't even I
can't even go eat anywhere because you
have to wear a suit to everything and I
refuse to wear a suit to a shitty
Bingo yeah yeah I bring all my own food
on the on the boat yeah you know who you
know who got me hip to all the good
stuff was Travis Barker yeah he doesn't
fly he used to he flies now though he
flies he started flying yeah since he
got together with uh Courtney he said
she made him he but he uh he
told me all these like little tricks I
got a studio set up there he used to do
it all the time
what how do you take food with you to
like stop off somewhere before do you
have like a meal prep I got all my [__]
right I like to cook I got all my [__]
ready they put it in the fridge for you
I bring I bring weed I like do my whole
thing and then I'm just out there I'm
like watching movies I'm probably
picking off I'm playing yeah it's
amazing I never want to come back and I
uh used to work on cruise ships as a
circus clown and um what year is this
today it was 19.99. okay and um they uh
this whole like uh circus clown on
cruise ships operation was um to be
implemented on the new world's largest
cruise ship it was like the so we
trained for like you know months
beforehand then we went out to Finland
where they built the world's largest
cruise ship and it had a fire on it and
[__] and so they were all behind
schedule and everything but uh we're out
there in Finland on like this
construction site of a cruise ship and
then it crossed the Atlantic for its
maiden voyage out of Miami you did that
yeah so I was I was on the the crossing
of the Atlantic of the world's largest
cruise ship which was like precisely
what the Titanic was I think you don't
even know about this guy
10 years 10 years you don't even know
I knew you this clown so you're gonna
get a lot of that I pulled out of people
that's good did you know that about him
uh I know a little bit about it
ah now the ship was built in turku
Finland and we crossed the Atlantic and
I was able to get a bunch of hashish to
keep myself roasting like where'd you
pick up the heat in Finland somewhere in
Finland yeah you can it's very easy the
if you want to kill anyone like I mean
like you can data they're really not
looking they're like oh yeah you're good
like you could bring anything on these
but I mean what are you gonna do kill a
bunch of like 90 year old people cruise
ships they're so big too huh yeah
they're huge is it like international
law like is the law no there is no law
they there's like in international
waters they have no laws really
hmm yeah because there's like no
jurisdiction
and there's no tax like sales tax on the
on the cruises right oh really I think
so yeah
if you go off the boat like I mean dude
you're you're [__] I remember recently
that just happened recently yeah a
couple days ago something like YouTube
kids yeah I don't even know if it's a
YouTuber I think it was just some
regular kid that did it for him for a
dare and then no and it was just so
gnarly I saw that video on TMZ yeah like
they threw in the life preserver the
little round like Lifesaver and like
they're like grab the Lifesaver and it's
just floating that way and the kid's
swimming the opposite way and you just
know dude so how did he die though I
mean dude you drowned you just drop like
in seconds
it's probably treading water for a
little bit of water you're trying until
you can anymore and said God that would
be just terrible it was probably cold
ass water so it's like how long can you
stay in an ice bath bore before you die
I think they were in some pretty
tropical location though hey did you see
that video of that kid you're just
laughing about it that's crazy you see
the video of that kid that was like at
the high school graduation and he jumped
in the water in the Bahamas and then
they were like trying to like get him in
a life preserver and a shark just takes
them under and he dies what no he just
disappears underwater I've seen a shark
you ever seen a shark yeah I've seen
many shirts he was like right where you
guys were for Shark Week okay and the
kid just went under and he died at his
high school graduation wow you didn't
see that no no no I'm oblivious to
anything that going on I did see that
that thing about the kid though because
I saw it and I was like well how did he
drown and there was all this stuff it's
like did he get sucked under did he you
know no I'm oblivious to everything but
shark damn I saw a shark a shark ran
into me one time but didn't bite me but
yeah they're they're not no and I have a
place in Malibu and there's all those
the sharks that aren't scary what are
those called Sand Sharks there's nurse
sharks they're not very scary I don't
know how big was it whale sharks are
really not scary yeah but those things
are huge
exactly it's a leopard shirt maybe this
big and then no I saw a big ass one in
the [__] like Caribbean or something
I was with my mom and they were like
shark and then like I saw it and I ran
back and then I saw my mom's not there
so I'm like [__] so guys we're gonna
swim back grab my mom and take her out
and luckily the [__] didn't didn't get
I'm not scared of sharks are you scared
of sharks I mean I wouldn't like love to
be big I'm scared of the unknown because
you can't see in there oh you're scared
of Dark Water yeah I mean I'm scared of
like it's in your head where all of a
sudden you're just gonna just disappear
dude I just want to say out of the gate
Benny Blanco favorite guest on the
podcast in ages yeah really yeah dude
you got good energy Mike Tyson what do
you mean Mike Tyson's the best yeah yeah
I said an age
now you know I always me and my friends
always talk about this do you think okay
so they give you a hundred million
dollars right now okay right now and you
got to get in the ring with Tyson right
now okay a are you doing it and then B
does he kill you if he hit like if he
hits you like a few times are you dead I
think if you let him uppercut you you're
dead like are you you dead if you just
like get like just your head just like
fly off your body yeah I think so here's
something that I I haven't uh talked
about on the podcast yet a couple weeks
ago I was um at the the UFC the you know
the the Octagon the fights you know and
um
I uh I'm talking to Steve will do it the
milk boys guy oh yeah I'm like yeah dude
when we get together we make kids that's
what are we gonna do and it's got to be
here because I'm getting on the road go
to go home and ever think about it I go
dude why don't we get choked unconscious
in the middle of the octagon and and
Steve will do it's like kind of not and
do it he's like oh I don't know I'm like
dude it's nothing it's there whatever
you know like it's like you know I'm
like it's kind of creepy you know it's
kind of creepy because you can't breathe
and you're being strangled you know and
like
let's just go out but then you just wake
up and you're like whoa that was awesome
and uh I really really put pressure on
him to do it but um like uh first we
went over to uh the the number three
middleweight contender in the UFC Marv
inventory great guy and I'm like hey
Marvin dude like you want to choke us
out and he's like totally dude let's do
it and uh and then I went over like uh
statistic to you know clear it with the
the powers that be and they're like
then I got Michael Bisping former world
champion UFC Hall of Famer and he's like
dude totally down and um I was nervous
before doing it because I have a
condition with my neck called
degenerative disc disease like where
like the space in between my vertebrae
is like like decreasing and decreasing
like it's you know my neck's just kind
of messed up and I'm thinking man this
probably isn't that great for my neck
and and uh you know before we do it
Marvin's gonna chug out Steve will do it
bisping's gonna choke me out I'm we're
in the middle of the Octagon after the
fight and um and I'm like yeah you know
maybe be easy on my neck because it's
kind of messed up and it might this
makes sense to Stephen how old are you
he says 24 because how old am I I go
48.
right in that remember when I said I'm
48 it struck me like I'm probably too
old to be doing this you know and and
when they do it I wake up I don't know
where I am or I'm like whoa but before I
even figured out where I was I'm like my
neck is not okay I thought I swear dude
I was so freaked out I honestly like I
honestly thought that I had just done
like the worst damage by doing that like
my like I've been for a while after I'm
like dude I'm not okay I just dude I
just got my neck wrecked you were
freaked out I'm sitting there filming
you and like while you're out your
mouth's twitching and you're drooling
and I'm just like switching and
dribbling
he's getting choked out like similar to
whippets when you wake up it's very
similar to being doing a whipping yeah
this man this man can do 3 000 whippets
in one sitting it's insane it's insane
it's truly
house turns like you should make the
color purple
oh my God he'll do it dude we went to a
like a fancy dinner we literally go to
like this fancy dinner in New York it's
like like like thousands of dollars like
this meal and he comes in and I'm like
because we're going to a party after and
he comes in with a can a huge canister
on this thing he's like all right I'm
good when you say canister do you mean
tank no he didn't have a tent he didn't
have a tank but I do have a video like
the restaurants
because that's how that's all you can
buy like the crackers and stuff it's all
you can buy in um in New York and then
no when we went to Vegas he had a man a
man literally brought a briefcase up and
we were like what is this and he just
opened it up and it was just a full
nitrous tank like we took it to the
restaurant
like uh so you like whippets honestly I
I don't do I don't do whip-its I I when
I was like a young kid like I grew up in
middle of nowhere
um and there's nothing to do so like we
all did them when we were kids but I
really don't do I don't really [__] with
drugs as an adult like I do like
mushrooms and weed but like um like I
don't know I honestly it doesn't like I
don't love the way it feels as an adult
like when you're a kid it's cool like we
did that and we used to do the thing
where you pass your friend out yeah you
know when you're a kid you like to like
dude there's nothing I grew up in the
middle of [__] nowhere you're like oh
you're like all right we should do
whippets and then pass the person out
when we were like in like seventh grade
that's like where you hyperventilate
hyperventilate you're crouching down and
you get up and do it like uh that's kind
of like being choked out oh is that what
it feels I don't do anything exactly the
same thing except take away the
hyperventilating
instead of your friend who's 120 pounds
you have like some guy who's like 300
pounds doing it that's crazy yeah I went
dude I thought my my vertebrae were
going to be fused together I thought I
was just done and then like
that's just for a couple days then a
couple days later I was like man dude I
feel better than ever like I think that
Michael bisping's like the magic
chiropractor we should send up some
flowers or something was that the
scariest thing you ever I mean in in
recent times that's like the I was I was
super bummed
scariest thing you ever did I mean I I
don't know it's all pretty subjective
Mafia toss nah I knew that would be fine
I just said I don't I'm afraid of
heights and stuff roller coasters yeah I
mean I don't I don't like them but
that's not like oh I'm screwed forever I
love a roller coaster I hate roller
coasters I don't like it I get nauseous
you get nauseous whenever you just close
your eyes if you start together I'm like
such a [__] when it comes to I get
carsick easily oh man I love I love I
love being tossed around like that's my
favorite feeling like I sleep for like
50 hours straight if I'm on a tour but
like I can just sleep the whole time wow
I love being tossed around
um
when you see Eric with the with the
whippets do you ever worry like man this
is maybe getting a little
no no does he pass out and like no no no
he's fine there he'll tell you right on
the thing no they're uh no he's Eric's
like really smart he has like he's like
he's like uh like like shamans they
bring like the perfect amount of like
drugs and like administer it correctly
like he's not like he's not going crazy
oh and he like reads all like if you're
like oh man like you're doing too many
whippets he's like well actually in 1987
and he has like every statistic so
you're like it sounds right I used to do
too much like when I was doing whippets
and I famously did a lot of it it's like
my entire purpose every time would be to
hold my breath and and pass out you know
like just huff and huff and huff I would
not
I would not even breathe in Air I'd be
like and while I I'd inhale the nitrous
hold it while I'm holding it in I'm
cracking the next thing so I blow out
the nitrogen I just inhaling more
nitrous like there's no air how many how
many times a day were you passing out
you think I mean 100 not a hundred but
on a good day like everything you say is
the craziest thing
every single thing is insane you no
wonder you guys haven't heard any of
these stories like it's like it's insane
again
I've never passed down one time in my
whole life once oh yeah one yeah I I was
like a kid and I had like an anxiety I
don't know I was having like anxiety
when I was like 18 or 19 and I just like
passed out that's the only time I ever
passed in my life never passed out I
used to hold my breath as a kid and pass
out really my mom would say that wow did
I get so mad like
like
I forgot over sleep what do you sleep
what are you you're old
what do you what do you sleep at night
what are we talking it depends like uh
anywhere I I've been trying to do six to
eight hours oh yeah that's great but
like on the road it's like four but the
problem with me is like I'm waking up
I'm probably waking up 20 times a night
oh you wake up every two hours every
hour you got pissed or something no I
wake up to piss a lot you wake up to pee
yeah I pee more than anybody in the
world really do you wake up a lot no no
yeah
how many hours you sleep in eight like
it's not like seven to nine yeah I you
know I wore one of those stupid things
like I was getting fit one time is that
it yeah that looks like a [__] it
looks like you're in jail like house or
fast
it's the most sophisticated Fitness
tracking device it's better than all the
other ones it's helping me sleep better
you think it's better than
you never have to take it off so what
okay
okay okay okay so what is that thing
doing it measures like your heart rate
variability
in temperature this guy this sponsor is
your thing yeah but yeah
but I liked it so much I bought a year
subscription really yeah yeah and they
didn't sponsor you just to say but
what's the difference between the Apple
watch
this is not the part of the program that
we actually get paid to talk about we
love it so much we don't even they're
probably not even on this podcast
lo and behold this episode is actually
brought to you by whoop and I'm thrilled
about that because I'm telling you I'm
doing a lot of things right lately I
think maybe because I'm sleeping with a
CPAP machine due to my sleep apnea my
sleep is like really better uh it's
showing in my analytics on whoop because
my recovery is great my heart rate
variability is in triple digits every
day for a long time and my buddies will
tell you that's amazing
um just this whole thing is is awesome
and I think it's time for you to try it
plus if you want to try it you're going
to get 10 off so you go to whoop.com
that's
w-h-o-o-p.com you use the promo code
Stevo at checkout and again you get 10
off
um it's just a great Community to be in
and how many people have we talked to
who just swear by this man Steve Aoki is
going to be jealous of how much my heart
rate variability has gone up I'm telling
you
um give it a shot go to whoop.com and
use the promo code Stevo yeah dude let's
get back to it yo but I wore one of
those things for a full year a whole
year and in the whole year only once did
I sleep more than seven hours in the
whole year is that is that is that
normal oh are you pouring no I just
don't I don't like I sleep if I'm on
like a butt I'm always doing so much I
don't have and then like by the time I
go to sleep it's like late and I wake up
I'm like one of those people who wakes
up at the [__] crack of dawn every
day that's him do you I'm up all nights
at Five today yeah I just wake up and
I'm like I don't drink coffee I don't do
like I'm just like I'm just like ready
to go like right away I'm like I'm like
I like wake up and I do like a front
flip out of bed and I'm like What's Up
yeah was it always like that yeah my
whole life my whole family's like that
we're like we're like just [__]
Juiced I'm like very happy like I wake
up every day I'm happy I don't wake up
sad ever like I just wake up and I'm
just ready yeah that's Epic Man what do
you do on tour uh well I wasn't well I
wasn't even I wasn't even on tour
basically I have to talk I basically
have to tour by by going to like work so
basically I was just going I put all my
work in a row because I take a tour bus
so I put all my work in a row that I
have to do so basically I had to go to
New York and I was like you know I was
working on my album I have this song
like I had to finish with Ed Sheeran in
New York so I go to New York and then I
was with like
just some friends out there I took some
time I have a I'm oh I don't even know
if I'm supposed to say I'm doing a book
but I have like a book so I had to like
go meet with like my book publishers and
she then I had to go to Atlanta to film
uh to like also work in the studio with
a bunch of people and then I was filming
with you know that guy sent it he's like
the biggest streamer in the world oh
yeah he's like he's amazing he's
incredible he's the funniest dude in the
world so I had to go film with him and
then I went to New Orleans to go do some
work and then my friend uh is this
musician Zach Bryan he's like this
country dude he's it's crazy this guy's
like became the biggest country guy in
the world like overnight like it's like
it's insane he did I used to see him
when he was doing like a thousand kids
now he does like 50 000 people it's
insane and he's this kind of cool ass
dude and then
then I uh then I actually went on
vacation for a few days so I like went
to and my mom had never really been to
Austin so I like flew her out she went
to Austin and then I took her to like
Arizona and then and then I had to go
work in Vegas because my trip got cut
short because we I do this show uh with
a little Dicky called Dave and
um we had to finish
season finale had Brad Pitt in it so so
we had to but Brad Pitt sings a song in
the in the show so I had to like get to
a studio and I was in the middle of
nowhere in Arizona so I'd like get to a
studio and finish all the Brad Pitt
vocals so it could be ready to air in
like three days so it was like that was
my trip that was my trip and that was a
month because I'm driving everywhere you
have a driver full-time no I just rent
one when we when we do the when I do the
trips and then now I'm now I'm here
[__] chilling and working and trying
to stay still for a little while I like
I like staying still what's the deal
with your garden it's beautiful oh yeah
I like you have corn yeah yeah yeah you
got a bunch of [__] yeah so so
yeah I do wait you just when you first
been getting here you're like I'm on a
garden over here okay I always I always
I always loved Garden like I always
loved like that I'm like really into to
like cooking yeah and you know I always
want to go to like farmers markets and
like see exactly where it's coming from
and I want to put like
most of the time I like to eat really
like healthy and then like other than
that like I like burn a hole through my
stomach like when I was traveling I all
I did was just drink and eat like all
day and then when I come back I'm like
okay I gotta be healthy and I was like
into like very into like knowing what's
going into my body and I started growing
my own [__] and then I started growing
weed and like uh
honestly we started with weed and we
were like oh we'll grow like one or two
plants but the first year we we grew
like 10 pounds and I was like what the f
and then last year we grew like 30
pounds of weed and you got you got it
right yeah yeah I have my friend my
friend uh Skelly owns this thing called
710 labs and it's like the best weed
company and he like helped me with the
seeds and I have like this guy named
Scott who um used to do all like the
stuff for like French Laundry and like
per se like he's like high level he like
helped me put it all together and he's a
Michelin grower yeah it's crazy he's
incredible and we started growing and
then I was like wait uh you know I do a
lot of Charity so I was like
I want to do something so like
people people who you know because you
go to these food deserts in like the
middle of nowhere in the middle like
east east L.A and it's like really hard
to get like high level fresh vegetables
so I was like I want to team up I teamed
up with this
um this lady named Maggie with support
and feed it's Billy eilish's mom Phineas
and and I'd done work with them before
so I started growing here so every week
they pick up boxes and bring it to
people all over that can't have it and
I've uh you know my goal is to just get
it bigger and bigger so it can just like
feel that's cool yeah that's really cool
that's crazy like if you think about how
they've just basically engineered weed
to be so unbelievably powerful
would follow that you could engineer
vegetables to be unbelievably nutritious
you're not used to like do do any of you
guys cook at all or not really yeah I do
okay okay do you ever go to a farmer's
market yeah okay so you ever taste the
vegetables you get a [__] like a
grocery store versus a farmer's market
yeah okay they taste so different now
think about when you grow yourself like
you're I'm watching this [__] start from
a seed and then it grows into like a
[__] corn husk and then like you like
take that corn husk you like put it in a
bag put it in the microwave and then
it's like popcorn like you made your and
it also makes you not want to waste
because I'm like I'm not wasting one
[__] leaf for this I saw this thing
grow for six months like I'm not wasting
one like and it's like cool so you got
like hydroponic dank ass porn
no it's really cool because like and
then like everything so all my waste
becomes compost and then we and then it
it's all like a [__] Circle alive
what was that toilet that we saw where
you take a [__] and then it incinerates
it and you pour the ashes on your garden
yeah dude do you know what I was
thinking about I was in the bathroom
with my friend so me and one of them me
and Dave actually he's like
actually like my best friend in real
life too so like we were in a party the
other night and like usually if one of
us has to shoot at the party like we go
in with each other and we just like talk
[__] smoke weed like while we're
taking a [__] so like so so he's taking
this [__] yeah so he's taking a [__] and
I'm sitting there he's like where you're
sitting and he's taking a [__] and I'm
sitting on like the like a bathtub and I
was like oh my God you know it'll be so
amazing if like there was like we every
I was like I'm gonna build us a toilet
like a bathroom where you could take it
and I could take it and we can just be
sitting right across from each other
while we're hitting like it would be
incredible just two toilets facing each
other
yeah they're going into each other's
eyes dude one time one time we were
shooting we were at like The
Chainsmokers house or some [__] and we
were like
and we're like we're sitting there and
we're sitting and um and uh first he was
taking it I was taking a [__] and then
he was like I gotta too so he took like
the nastiest it was like the power of
dual [__] it's like we took the
smelliest like yeah dirty [__] and then
like as we're walking out I don't even
want to say like a huge like
pop star happened to be like walking in
with some guy she was gonna hook up with
and like we were just walking out and
then like and then like like as we
walked out like I just heard them be
like they're like oh they're like this
rooster I was like [__] and they were
just about to [__] each other in the
room and we were just we were the
Poo-Pourri that like gave them whatever
yeah it was yeah cockpot I blocked him
it was crazy yeah yeah
you're constipated I already know
like the little poops that are like that
bird seed or like the ones that look
like they have muscles that hurt when
they come out like it's a legitimate
concern sometimes like will that even
flush
those are the big ones like yeah like
big old like every day not every day
like and like every two or three days
wait you don't get for two or three days
sometimes I will not poop for two or
three days and then the toilet will be
just straight full and I'm like is that
even gonna flush wow and sometimes
every day like I'm spiritually off yeah
I'm depressed every morning like like if
I don't I feel like I'm just like I'm
like am I gonna be buggish yeah like
depressed sometimes I got like it's it's
not flushing and I'm like damn and and I
gotta like
show me what these are talking are they
like longer than this well like how wide
how wide yeah
well it'll start out like a log it's
like the microphone
it'll start out like a log and then
after that it's it's just straight like
like that not like that video two girls
one cut oh yeah okay and then the rest
is just a big old milkshake
you eat bad you eat good though I mean
I'm all over the place are you a healthy
are you a healthy guy
I'm a moving Target sometimes I'm really
healthy sometimes I'm not but um I've
just started a stretching regimen every
morning
I won't let myself drink coffee until
I've done my full stretch routine when
you were like 18 were you like man when
I'm 48 I'm gonna be having a stretching
regimen every [__] I never thought I
would make it to 30. crazy that not only
did I make it to 30. now I'm pushing 50.
and when you get up to these ages man it
is super important to take care of
yourself and your diet is such a huge
piece of that that's why I swear by ag1
this is a nutritional supplement which
fills in all the gaps in my diet and it
is a ritual that begins every day I do
my meditation my stretching and then I
drank my ag1 and then I have my coffee
and this stuff really does it all man it
helps with gut health cognitive ability
I'm filling in all the gaps in your diet
it's got 75 different vitamins and
minerals and Whole Foods sourced
superfoods and I mean it's crazy and you
can have five convenient comprehensive
nutrition travel packs plus an entire
year supply of immune boosting vitamin D
if you go to drink
ag1.com
Stevo and this is a new landing page so
again it's drink
ag1.com
Stevo for five free travel packs and all
that vitamin D with your first purchase
hurry up and get on over there to jump
on this deal and let's get back to it
yeah I'm shocked how old are you I'm 35.
35. you know what's crazy I was like on
that thing with uh with Kai the other
day and everyone was saying their ages
and they're like man you're old they
were talking like their friend they were
like man you're 24 year old and then I
told them my age and they didn't believe
they made me show my ID they were like
now I know I'm like starting to get old
yeah they were like they're like what
are you talking about you're not 35 and
I was like yeah I'm 35 like and they
were like and they were like clowning me
like they were like one of them said one
of the dudes was like I've never even
met anyone that's not like a parent
that's that's that old and I was like
I'm 30 I'm not even old like I'm not
yeah I mean it's it's relative how old
do you think I am
you old I don't know
he was all this man how do I look okay
okay you I'm the worst with age everyone
in here that's walking up to someone
saying Hey man can I get you to kick me
in the nuts
everyone in my in my head like I'm also
like I'm also the shortest person in
every room so every person I'm like oh I
don't know they're like I'm I'm so off
by Heights okay so here's here's what I
would get in my head like I would just
be like oh we're all the same age okay
but now that I'm like I'm gonna like try
to guess perfectly
I think you're how would you say you
were I'm 48. okay and you're what 35.
you're like we all look the same uh okay
I'm gonna guess you're
42 40. that's good I'm close I'm close
yeah my yeah like like my brother like
my brother's like 40 you got everyone
looks the [__] same like once you're
like a certain age it's all the same
until you're like 60. like everything's
the same yeah I think the gray hair
throws people off for me you look hot
you got a wife nope you single yep
yeah you have a friend
wait uh you got kids nope
have you have you been married never oh
wow wow you're like I have no STDs or
anything dude you're like so hot and
like cool yeah and he's a he's a
mile-high Legend dude a mile high Legend
we got on an airplane in L.A yeah in L.A
London yeah and like just happened to be
sitting next to like the hottest chick
that like like you don't normally see
chicks that hot on an airplane and like
she's sitting next to him in in business
class where you've got like the
partitions kind of deal yeah and then
lay down seats and then they go down and
it's like a bed and like that just
happened to be next to the smoking hot
as Venezuelan chick and you did it at
all time did it you did had it take me
through how it happened I'll be the sway
Lindley
so what happened I want you to show me
everything
now we just we're like talking really
well how long is the flight I mean L.A
to London oh 12 hours 12 hours but I
boned her within like the first hour and
a half two hours you did yeah are you
are you guys still friends I wish what
she was you were terrible she was like
no no we met back up and that was the
first time I mean we've been working
together 10 years and I've never seen
this wiener really but this Venezuelan
chick on that airplane said it was huge
wait you you got a huge dick I mean
according to South Americans wait have
you never seen I've seen every one of my
friends dicks like everything I know Sam
you've never seen Scott I've never seen
this you know people seen my dad do you
know like my friend some people are like
I think it's crazy like I've seen you've
seen everyone in your friends dicks
right like almost I've never seen
Vinnie's dick I don't think no even in a
picture yeah I sucked most of them
like I've seen oh my God like when I was
a kid one of my friends pissed in my
mouth like yeah
dude we did all we used to do like crazy
[__] like just like for fun like what
would you say you're like dude no my
friend pissed in my mouth really he like
we were in like a squirt gun fight and
he like he went to the bathroom and he
pissed in the thing and he came back and
he was like scoring us and I was like I
was like this one tastes weird I was
like ah and like I opened that and I was
like keep spraying I'm trying to figure
out what it was and I was like what I
was like did you put like fish in that
like you tasted piss before
uh yeah I'm sure like sure like it it
tastes kind of like tastes kind of crazy
I read a thing where piss was good for
you so like I went through a spirit
where I drank my own piss that's crazy
no wonder yeah yeah but you got sick
what type of sickness is it just like
the flu
wait okay wait so I want to go back I
want to go back to okay airplane yeah so
you're on the airplane you had sex with
this girl um within like one hour and
and mile high club first of all mile
high club is so crazy one of my friends
actually this is a crazy story okay so
my friend my friend is uh is a friend of
mine he's a he's a musician and he's
famous and he's famous and he's on we're
like taking
we're flying back I'm I actually flew
we're flying I was like I'm very scared
but it was a close flight we were in
Vegas and we're flying back and
he's like
whoa he's like okay
he's he's like this this girl really
likes me and he's like
think I could have sex on an airplane
and he's like but I'm so scared like I'm
so scared of this like I've I like
I'm scared to STD like I I don't I don't
want to do this and he was like ah but
maybe I do it's such a cool thing like
it's so cool to be like in the mile high
club and he was like uh
okay I'm gonna try it and so he like
gets and his friends like yeah you gotta
do it everyone's like egging him on in
the back he's like okay so how am I
gonna do it like what do I do and he was
like nervous he was like do I like do I
do I like prepare an area like in the
back like what do I do like we're on
like a jet he's like do I like and he's
like okay so like guys I'm gonna have
like a signal like I'm gonna have like a
whole he's preparing this whole thing
he's like calling all his friends in the
airport like bathroom like all his other
friends who are like artists and he's
like when you do the mile high club on a
jet like what do you do so like finally
we're on the jet these girls are on the
thing and and
um he's like okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna have a signal and he's like he
tells everyone he's like I'm gonna go to
the bathroom and he had like made an
area in the bathroom already with like
cushions on the ground he thought he was
gonna do this whole thing I mean it's
like a nor it's teeny so he so he he's
like okay I'm gonna go to the back now
and he like sets it all up and then he
comes back and then he's like talking to
the girl and the girl was so into him
and then he's like
you want to like should we like go to
the back and she's like no and he's like
wait he's like what do you mean and
she's like and she's like going to the
back with you she's like I just met you
and he's like what he's like you're on
like you can't you're so into it and
she's like I'm not going to the back
with you I'm not like just like some
like groupie that's gonna and so then
like it was that was at the very
beginning of the flight some were
sitting there for an hour and he's just
like so mad yeah it was crazy and it's
like first of all it felt like they were
like in love it felt like they were in
love at the beginning like I thought
like for sure this was gonna happen so
he's like planning this whole thing out
there's just there's just like cushion
every time everyone went to the bathroom
they were like why is there all these
cushions in the back and he just like
didn't do it and then like later that
night she tried to hang out with him
again and he was just like so confused
and rattled and sad for me very
different from your cushion experience
from your sex and you had sex in the
seat
okay tell it tell us everything well
it's so it
we ended up shooting the [__] and
talking and then like we kind of did
this thing where it was uh we just
started making out you know and then did
this thing where you just start making
are you in a different seat did you get
in this so we're in the same seat so I
the way I talked about this on the last
podcast so like we were we took off in
the air and she was like
um and I was like oh it's crazy like I'm
not even feeling this flight like it's
not that bumpy and she's like oh we're
not even in the air yet and I said yeah
we are and it was like bet and I was
like all right if I'm right you give me
a kiss and so then we started making out
and then you said if I'm right if we're
in the air then then you give me a kiss
and then it's like high school like you
know is that what you do with every date
no take a girl on a flight it was like
we're in the hair give me a kiss and
then it was just kind of the vibe and
then we started making out and then so
cool and then like we had the blanket
you know and then she just went under
and started sucking my dick and I was
like oh [__] like it's on
and then I'm getting a [__] which was
kind of like uncomfortable because I'm
like looking up and the thing it's kind
of like just people walking by and [__]
and then as they turned the lights down
after like the food service like she
just took her pants off and rolled over
and did you use a rubber
yeah rubber
do you use and do you use protection I
mean normally but like I didn't have
protection I wasn't thinking I was gonna
[__] on a flight
yeah wow but I mean I'm not gonna be the
guy to turn down like the hottest chick
in the world but she's the hottest chick
in the world
because I was in the seating he was
supposed to be in the city you you wait
it was supposed to be him and then he's
like yo you're my seat get up and we
switch seats and then all of a sudden
this chick came Saturday but you would
have never had a chance you're not
you're not good like that right
I'm guessing that I would not have do
you have like good game yeah I don't
know were you with Lux back then no no
no no this was uh like the end of
November 2016. what would your would you
have been able to make it happen or no
no here's the thing
um I'm saying even though it's cool that
your buddy that you're talking about was
that it was on a private jet I'm
claiming that doesn't count because he
knew the person before
well he didn't even do it
not like you got to meet the person on
the plane I'm so scared of flying this
is never like any one of my girlfriends
that like tries to get me to fly on a
plane they're like oh I'm like that's my
worst nightmare like when I get on a
plane you see that thing there with the
time on it I don't miss one minute on
the thing I'm just like glued to the
thing staring at it were you always like
that no no I used to fly all the time
dude I Le and I'm so anxious about
flying I can take
uh I can take Xanax and and like and
like it does nothing on the flight I can
take like three of them and they do
nothing and then when I get off I'm like
unconscious because the adrenaline yeah
what do you think it is
like a control issue did it sort of
happen when you started making money no
it started happening I had like some bad
flights and I got in my [__] head
there's one guy got me on a plane you
guys know Carrie Gainer oh my God if you
ever want to quit anything do I need to
smoke cigarettes or anything I smoke a
stupid bait he can get you to he has a
hundred percent success rate and he
gives you your money back if he doesn't
if it if he doesn't work and he's never
had anyone and but he meets you the
first time and he'll be like
you can do it or he'll be like nah
you're not ready yet so he's got you to
fly he's got me to fly three times
the only person since like and then I've
flown a few times like like on my own
but he's like the only guy who's like
really gotten me to do it and like not
be scared
and when he got you applied three times
that that he he managed to get you on a
private jet I flew both I've flown on a
private jet and a uh commercial with him
he's he's really good he gets people to
quit everything hmm he's crazy
yeah he's amazing so okay so you had so
we're getting back to and then you had
sex and so so how are you not why don't
you have a wife
I don't know I think I think you got
them ready yeah he gets claustrophobic
are you claustrophobic but I think for
me now like I never wanted to be in a
relationship with somebody until like I
traveled and did everything wow
he wanted like to to have a house like
to be set up so that he kind of has
something to offer yeah yeah I just
bought a house but like there would be
like you know a level of Shame around
like bringing a girl back to a studio
apartment where I'm like I don't know
really yeah I think just as my idea of
like I said that to me yesterday I don't
think there's any someone was to talk we
were talking about like
how to take someone out on a date and he
was just like oh and I was like oh you
gotta cook like I and he was like I
can't cook I have a studio apartment I
got one he said I only have one pot and
I was like what do you mean that should
be like your setup like you go to the
girl you're like look I got one pot so
what do you like to eat anything we
could put in one pot I'm good like you
just like make it part of the thing yeah
it wasn't even about yourself it was
like it was that I want to be in a place
to where I can like be a provider yeah
yeah now you're a provider and I'm a big
dicks big provider they call me Daddy
they call you Daddy Daddy Gray beard
provider I might have someone for you
okay
what are you looking for
you don't know I I when I look I I think
she likes big boobs I like big boobs but
like I like I like I like funny girls
okay so a funny girl with big boobs okay
okay was the Venezuelan girl funny
I didn't really talk to her
have you ever been in touch with her in
the last well we met back we met up when
when I were in London again and then I
reached out to her and she never
responded uh perfect are you just like a
Playboy no you you have girlfriends ever
sometimes oh my God it's been a
nightmare yeah I like red flags but like
being in therapy like I'm trying to like
communicate more and like really work on
that kind of stuff so I'm not really
trying to date red flags you sound
communicative
yeah you sound good yeah we should find
him somewhere yeah for sure okay he's
like yeah for sure shut the [__] up
I mean you know has anyone talked about
this and on the podcast no I mean maybe
we've talked about sex addiction and you
got sex addiction yeah oh you do I mean
we we started working together because
you have both our sexy yeah like I got I
went to sex addict rehab yeah you're a
sex addict in 2013 I went into
um what was called an IOP intensive
outpatient treatment for sex addiction
really yeah and as soon as I got out of
there I had to go back on tour right
that's not a touring comedy clubs and
every week I'd go out to some different
city and I'm like dude I'm a dead duck
like I need I need a um to bring like a
car
so I reached out to Scott oh cause you
were also in it yeah something like a
[__] blocker yeah January 2014 I was
like hey I gotta go on this trip on tour
and like it's so important to me that I
not act out sexually I gotta maintain my
sexual sobriety can you come with me on
tour and help support me so he's a
professional [__] blocker so we like
share a room so it's like you know
you're not gonna have a chick come back
to the room if you're like I got this
guy in there wow so
um you so what is it like how how often
were you having sex I mean the
definition of sex addiction is any
sexual compulsive behavior that causes
shame so it's different for everybody oh
so there could be a guy who never has
sex but he's a sex addict he's a sexual
anorexic and that's a problem too or
like you know porn pornography super
Insidious like people would just be a
sex addict there are people who will
spend like eight hours a day watching
porn were you one of those people I've
been there when I went yeah when I was a
therapist up there when I went to a
therapist like he was like you watch
porn and I said yeah and he goes for how
long like eight hours a day or like as
quick as you can then you're done and I
was like as quick as I can then I'm done
back to work he's like I guess there's
two types of people
that's right and let me tell you there
are two types of razors too the kind
that you pay way too much money for with
dumb gimmicks you don't need and then
there's the razors from Harry's which
are as quality as razors can possibly
come classy elegant and totally
affordable plus with the new craft
handle it's never been more satisfying
to hold a razor and this craft handle
comes with the craft starter kit which
is a 17 value coming with the five blade
razor the travel cover for the razor the
weighted ergonomic craft handle the
foaming shave gel 17 value but you get
it for just 10 bucks if you go to
harrys.com
Stevo I swear by these products I've
used them for years now and I never plan
on using any other products to shave my
face so so to jump on this deal one more
time you go to harrys.com
Stevo and you're going to be glad you
did now let's get back to it
oh I like to I like to stretch out my
jerk off experience yeah that's called
edging yeah of course I've used edging
I'm doing like a I'm like my [__] is
like
[__] tight like we're doing like I
got like 80 windows open at once I'm
going back and forth just trying to find
the best thing I'm teasing myself for
hour hour yeah hour time yeah I like at
least 30 minutes minimum are all these
porn windows that are open the same type
of porn is it all different oh it's it's
all across the Spectrum I got 60 TVs
going at once no I'm just kidding I'm
like a gambler you have the VR headsets
uh uh I got one once I'm not into it
like uh Dave used to be really into it
he loved it he was like he he had like a
a thing Auto blow this thing I bought
one because I saw it on the show oh man
I got like 60 of them upstairs you don't
like you like it it's not bad
it's like
yeah the owner right when we did it the
owner sent me like 200. I he was like so
anytime someone comes over to my house
I'm like here I'm like have a water and
an auto blow and take it home like it's
it's crazy yeah I like I don't know I
like
I like a laundry you like a long or
short joke what like like how how short
as fast as I can than the back door how
fast can you do it I mean depends how
long it's been but like at three minutes
two minutes you like a short one or a
long one
I have a strict no porno rule like I I I
I just can't I can't mess it up I'm if
I'm jerking off at straight spank bank
and it's you know it's a speed round
speed round okay yeah I'm a sprinter oh
yeah okay okay so you guys aren't you're
not allowed to look at porn I yeah I
just don't do it it's been years since
yeah I got back off of it so I started
watching it again then I then I haven't
yeah I had I had a little spell there
where I determined that Tick Tock is not
porn Tick Tock account right and so that
that wouldn't take more time because I'd
be like going through Tick Tock looking
like like cute chicks like like acting
cute you know and like it's not a big
hot chicks on Tick Tock it's not
effective
it's like what that would like really be
yeah the thing about like say if you
watch porn you deprive yourself of porn
and like you're like okay I'm not gonna
watch anymore then all of a sudden
you're like but then you notice yourself
like on Tick Tock like spending a lot of
time you're like there's like a fine
line and it's like a constant like
moving goals what's the most you jerked
off in a day eight so many you said nine
maybe nine what about you ah man I
remember when I was uh in like seventh
grade I would get in the shower and
there was like a special faucet just for
your feet
it was a shower and but at the bottom
there was another faucet for washing off
your feet and I would crawl under that
and put my wiener under the foot faucet
and like and and I would just you know I
hadn't even figured out that you could
do it with your hand I didn't even know
I thought I was just on to something
that nobody had ever done and uh I
remember
yeah but nothing would come out yeah it
was the best when you could come when
nothing would come out I wish I could go
back to that
I remember calling my brother I begged
my brother I was like teach me how to
come like it's so crazy I asked my
brother I was like how do you come I was
like I just want to come so bad because
I wanted stuff to come out because I was
jerking off before that could happen and
then I remember I was at Sleepaway Camp
and like I finally I jerked off in one
drop came out like what it was like it
was like like just how old are you when
that happened like 12. I was 13. yeah so
seventh grade dude I'm 12. and I was for
sure 13. dude I was 12 and I remember
you got one call a month like you could
do one call at camp and like to call
your parents yeah call your parents but
one call every two weeks you could call
your parents I ran and I left a message
on uh on my brother's cell phone he had
like this is like when like cell he like
had a cell phone because he was at
College at the time and like he was like
the only guy like with the like no one
had cell phones back then and I remember
I left a message to tell that I came and
that was like that was like I was so
happy I cried I actually cried when the
one drop came out what's the most you've
ever jerked off in one day I'm not like
a he maybe maybe twice maybe two oh
really yeah maybe it came twice this
morning
I haven't jerked off since we've been
home from Australia how long is that
because you have a girl sucking your
dick
yeah yeah but I still jerk off I still
jerk off when I'm in a relationship I uh
pretty good lately about just saving it
up for my lady yeah you know you know uh
we we call it uh letting the cream Brew
so sometimes sometimes you gotta you're
like oh am I gonna waste the jerk up
like if like your girlfriend's out of
time like am I gonna waste it or should
I just let the cream bruise so it's like
like I like to shoot you a shooter are
you an oozer shooter shooter dude lately
I've been oozing you've been oozing I
used to be a shooter yeah you did what
happened I don't know getting lazy what
about you you shooting her I'm
definitely a shooter yeah I like I could
I I might like I could definitely hit
you from here like like like hit you
right in the eye okay you can hit Vinny
no I don't think I could hit him I could
hit you
I think I could I think like on like a
real good day I think I could hit that
water bottle wow it's got to be like
like and but not like the I think like
like debris could hit the water like
shrapnel yeah yeah you find like uh for
your like would you say saving the cream
Brewing the cream yeah let the cream
Brew let the cream like do you find that
like when you let the cream Brew you're
more creative when you create music
or does that I don't know yeah they say
like basketball players and stuff don't
you for sure I'm [__] like like for
me I like if I'm anxious or anything I
jerk off and then I feel 100 times
better yeah like that I'm sorry I just I
just interrupted and I try not to do
that I get better yeah that was bad I
was just struck by the thought we've got
like one of the most prolific music
producers
we're like an hour in and for the first
time we've talked about we've even
mentioned music yeah
jerk off strategy towards making good
music now jerking off and music is it
true that the First music you've ever
produced was for a porno yeah that
that's true that is true it was for real
yeah okay okay it was uh so basically
I'll tell you it would be uh yeah no no
this so so
um this guy who I worked with he he uh
he started Source map The Source
magazine it's like a huge rap magazine
and his name is Jonathan is Jonathan
Checker he's still alive uh and then he
also
had like a softcore porn series called
hip hop Honeys and I was like uh I was a
kid and I like stopped I stopped making
uh
like I stopped I was a rapper at first
and like I started making my own beats
and I was like oh my God like I want to
make beats for your series and he was
like okay I'll give you 200 bucks if you
like can make a beat and I was like 200.
I was like so happy I was like oh my God
and I get to get the porn for free so so
like I uh they I did it and I remember
it came and I was like so excited and I
had like all my friends over every day
and we'd like watch it my mom found him
she was like you can't have this thing
like I can't have all your friends
coming over just like jerking off at the
half like we would all take turns like I
swear to God I'd be like okay you can
watch the scene first and uh
and my mom like confiscated it from me
and I was like in all these porn it
being what a DVD or something yeah there
were DVDs and this was like right when
DVDs were really getting big like this
was you know I was probably 12 13 and
it's like 99 like this was like oh wow
like like this is like right when DVDs
were like starting to become like
everyone had a DVD player so how old
were you when you made the porno music
uh probably 12 or 13.
yeah I started I started really young
like I I I I got discovered like I got
offered a wreck my first record deal
when I was like 13. but like how did you
know what poor like I don't know what
porn was no no like porn music like no
it wasn't really porn music it was like
this dude it was hip hop yeah this this
guy no he decided he it was actually a
really smart idea he took all like the
video girls from all the famous music
videos and he was like Hey if any one of
you guys wanna uh like get naked and
dance to like Muse I don't know he made
like a software it wasn't really porn
like there was no dick like it was just
girls dancing with like their tops off
and stuff and I and it was making like
rap beats like I wasn't making like porn
it wasn't like
it was just like no it's just like porn
it was it was just like rap music so I
was like doing that and
and that's how it all started baby
yeah that'd be funny if like you were
making porn like like dude this this
porn is sick and it's made by a 13 year
old yeah yeah basically yeah yeah he's
just like making 13 you're just they're
like we get all 13 year olds to make all
our porn music yeah no it was uh yeah it
was interesting it was like is it that
was technically the first person to ever
buy one of my Beats so it was like porno
that's how that's how that's how it all
started for me yeah chucking beats yeah
exactly yeah that is crazy that we
didn't even talk about any but that
usually happens I could I'll talk about
anything except music
I mean dude it's Epic Man and and I I
will say it again like uh they're right
up there with my favorite guests of all
time oh man fun energy just you get some
time back your guests suck yes who's the
worst no you can't say I was about to
say well one guy that we had that we
couldn't even air is
[__] uh he was just so goddamn drunk
yeah it was something yeah oh you had
some you had someone who was too drunk
to hear yeah it was it was it was
upsetting it was upset it was like bro
we can't even play this like you will
not want us to play this tomorrow it was
an act of Mercy to not put that one out
oh my God what's the craziest thing
never happened on this pie Dave England
but that was that wasn't in this van it
was on our tour bus
yeah yeah
that's crazy and maybe we have Eric
Andre do whippets on the next one you
ever eaten before never
um animal sure oh yeah yeah
we we when we were kids
and no we got one of our friends at home
so we did this thing
where uh you remember like it was either
Domino's or Pizza Hut have those like
Buffalo kickers that were like so we we
took a [__] and then we cut them up and
then we like put them in the thing and
covered them in barbecue sauce or like
hot sauce or something and then my
friend like went to grab it and then he
like put in his mouth and they like
Munch down on it before he like knew and
then he instantly knew it was threw up
everywhere and he was so mad at us yeah
I bet it was insane and then and then
our other friend that same day he he hit
our other friend with a potato launcher
and like the guy like like ruined his
leg like ruined like if you get it no
dude if you get hit with like a potato
launcher like it's like it's like no
joke like he like couldn't walk for like
a week like they're like it's getting
blasted with like a bazooka yeah I I I
had somebody introduce me to a potato
launcher and we did a test fire against
this like kettle and like the cattle was
just and I was like wow that's too
gnarly so to shoot me with it we just
made like a ball of duct tape
and and we shot me with that and just a
ball of duct tape and it was like duct
tape wrapped around like tissue yeah
something and like it blasted it broke
the skin of my butt cheeks it was in the
whole circle yeah they were very far was
yours close I mean it was like from here
to Vinnie well I know ours was way
further what was the thing that shot you
in the year what gun was that with the
oh that was a T-shirt cannon and that
was hard
that was pretty gnarly yeah yeah like I
had to take a bunch of uh my dogs Poo
put it in the blender and and uh made it
into like milkshake kind of and then
filled it up with a T-shirt cannon with
it it ruptured his eardrum it had like
they shot me in the face with dogs from
like pretty point blank with the T-shirt
cannon and uh blasted a hole in my ear
drum with duck did you have like a
doctor on call like when you're like
when you were younger like dessert or do
you have like one doctor you've dealt
with forever no but I would say if I if
I went to the same hospital for all my
things I'd be on their uh Christmas card
yeah it's insane how many times you
think you've been to the hospital man
for an injury
I don't know what like
well the thing is you won't you only go
to the hospital when it's like [__]
have to like he tries to not go to the
hospital I've never asked for an x-ray
that didn't reveal a break you know like
a lot of people be like oh dude I need
to get an x-ray and they're like oh you
sprained your ankle like that's not me
like if I if I say like if my phones
have you broken uh that Bunch if you
count teeth it's like 20 something if
you don't count teeth it's like a dozen
how many teeth did you break like 10 or
so
yeah you ever broken a ball like two
when I was a kid yeah no yeah me neither
yeah he's uh Benny's pretty well
insulated yeah that's true
what's coming up next man whatever are
we we're promoting your your new album
no I haven't even it's not even coming
out yet I'm never promoting anything
dude what a bro what a bro you're not
even trying to promote you're just like
let's hang out I'm not even promoting
your cooking show yeah we got a cooking
show I got all this the promoting like I
never like do that it's so stupid it's
like yeah good thing like
go buy this thing like it's like I don't
give a [__] like if you yeah if you want
to check something out you can check it
out if not no I like it's for me it's
like it doesn't it doesn't matter how
many people go like you're watching a
thing and you're like oh my God I'm
definitely gonna switch apps and go
check this out it depends man I guess
apparently a lot yeah
it depends like sometimes well I have
something that we want to promote and
sell and we'll make video specifically
for that and depending on whether that
video gets people engaged in the story
and and it makes them you know like like
them the most [__] popular thing we
ever did I I got together with Tony Hawk
yeah and and we set up two ramps one
ramp for him one ramp for me and the
ramps were pushed up against the wall
and so like we're doing big wall rides
and I I'm he's doing a huge wall ride
over my wall ride
and there's this rad photo of us both
like in the middle of riding the wall
and um we printed out and photos and
signed them both of us signed them for
charity oh that's cool and that video
got people engaged in that and like how
much of a [__]
effort it was you know to like get that
to happen by the time it happened and
I'm like here's the photo we're both
signing them and like it's crazy we
raised a half a million dollars for
charity you good at skateboarding yeah
no no
a really good friend like he's just a
good guy and he's like oh like any time
I've reached out to Tony Hawk hey you
want to do this thing he's always that
goes for me jackass like all the way
back like he's just always been a bro
just down to do whatever yeah and um and
I was like here Tony I built a ramp on
onto my Tesla and I want to [__] have
it drive towards me I'm gonna jump on
and skate over the Tesla while it's
moving and I want you to drive it and
he's like yeah sure sweep dinner it's
like the most incredible [__] thing
yeah but the car was going so slow
because I suck at skateboarding yeah
yeah that nobody cares to get Tony Hawk
driving up skating over a moving car for
brand new Tesla nobody gave him so uh
now I'm now I'm gonna
um put it all back together the ramps on
the car and uh and have professional
skateboarders do it yeah yeah and you
drive it I don't know if I if I even
want to drive but yeah I probably should
you probably should I probably should do
you play any sports yeah I play sports
what basketball how about pickleball I
love pickleball do you yeah I love it
that's cute that's good it's like a game
where anyone can play like you can just
like you you instantly if you have any
hand-eye coordination you can play with
like a professional athlete and it
doesn't it doesn't even matter yeah we
played pickleball a couple times yeah I
saw David dobrik posted a video of him
playing pickleball yeah it was just like
crazy behind the back yeah yeah I was
just playing with him a day ago wow yeah
he's really where do you guys play in LA
uh in your backyard though we play it
one of our friends has like three
pickleball courts and we play I started
playing during covet yeah that's right
everyone started doing during coven you
get you get sweaty playing pickleball
you count it as exercises
you get sweaty playing pickleball that's
the craziest Quest I think that might be
the craziest question we got today
yeah I do I get so I'm not like a huge
sweater though I feel like you sweat you
could sweat no I mean I swear in the
sauna yeah yeah when you sweat a lot
yeah I swear yeah
I gotta really work out the sweat yeah
I'm not a big sweater you sweating now
yeah I'm sweating now it's a little hot
in here yeah I got a [__] seriously
workout to sweat yeah Warren Buffett say
you should just break a sweat every day
I'm like man he said it's a tall order
that's one above it's skinny or fat he's
fat as [__]
she's like 99.
[Music]
Warren Buffett's a slob is it wait
didn't Warren Buffett isn't he the guy
who also has McDonald's every morning
yeah yeah oh wow and depending on
whether the stock market's like up or
down he gets like it's like he'll spend
a dollar 38 if it's down he'll spend
2.38 if it's up honestly I was like his
he drives like his same car like he's in
Nebraska you saw that that video on him
yeah on YouTube yeah I saw that too yeah
there's like a and he's like really
talking about all the [__] and he's
like isn't he like one of the richest
dudes in the world yeah of all time
Berkshire Hathaway that's crazy you know
a lot about this stuff Kim you know a
lot about it I think bro you're worth
billions of dollars and you're eating
McDonald's like we get it do you eat
McDonald's
no I don't eat McDonald's I haven't
eaten McDonald's since like 2004. I'm
going to McDonald's just to take her
[__]
they do no they I mean I just think like
what McDonald's cool like I'll take it
you eat any fast food McDonald's I try
not to what about Raising Canes you
don't like that place I've never seen it
oh that's the ass chicken yeah raisins
what no like the I'll get like Mexican
food fast food okay like we're like uh I
don't know I've been eating a lot of Air
One lately oh man you're on that you're
really trying to get a wife now I'm
trying to get like yeah salmon buffalo
cauliflower you look good well thanks
dude these the jacket that body just
more if you had sweating balls in here
yeah kinda damn what you got all sex
addict bodies yeah we got a lot of
problems in this van guilt-free
no no it's just one screen yeah but okay
there's nothing in your life that like
causes you shame
I think Benny's pretty well adjusted man
I think he's living right and I think
you should back off
I I think maybe the flying thing I want
to get over that that's like my only bro
who are you dude that's sick you don't
have anything you're like
everybody's got something that's that I
think the flying thing
no I don't know like any secrets that
you're like [__] whatever no I don't
really have like I'm like a very open
book like it's everyone who knows me
it's like I say like whatever's on my
mind like I don't I'm not like yeah
that's probably the secret to it you're
just getting everything out I'm not
hiding anything like I'm I'm never
hiding anything like I say how I feel I
like yeah yeah it's like if you came
over he's like what's up you just
tricked off what are you doing yeah yeah
I say that's probably the way to live I
say whatever I feel like also if like I
don't like like if someone's like not
cool I'm like oh I'm like not gonna hang
out with this person anymore like I
don't like do I I try to like
keep like good people in my life and not
do
you know [__] like and like if I I
can definitely say no like be like oh I
don't want to do that this doesn't feel
good to me like if I went to the beach
and like uh I was with a couple chicks
and like I would take my shirt off I'd
be like I'm fat and like I would have
that like in my head the whole time no I
would never think about that you don't
even care no he's like why would I want
to be fat all right no I don't care no
no I don't even when I was even when I
was I was a lot heavier before uh you're
just down take your shirt off you don't
even think anybody's judging you well I
don't I don't care like if you really
like just are like if you're just
confident in yourself and you're always
yourself like you're gonna be it's like
it's like like I always like that saying
it's like
be yourself because everyone else is
taken so it's like I'm always gonna just
be me and it's and if you're always you
then people can't [__] with you on [__]
and if you're you and like I'm like a
funny guy so I'm like gonna make fun of
myself or something like I might say
something like like self-deprecating
like and I yeah I wouldn't worry about
no one gives this you think you think of
no I know nobody cares but like they can
see what you look like you think they're
like oh my God that guy probably has
like an eight pack underneath no this
either like oh they're like he's a sweet
guy and a girl doesn't want you to have
a better body than them I feel like
girls like Dad bods lately yeah what do
are you like what what do you you're
ashamed now yeah kinda why you look
great well thank you I think it's the
jacket what you think like you think
you're like a no I'm just overweight
like uh definitely like hot as [__]
underneath that jacket and like he's
wearing that jacket as a shield oh are
you actually no no I don't know I'm
actually wearing this because we have
two podcasts today and so then I'm gonna
take this off and then I'll work in the
next one what will you do wear the same
thing I I brought another t-shirt dude
I'm gonna wear my Beaver linkers t-shirt
I should have got that no he's like why
didn't I wear that it's a good question
you should have worn it from me wait so
okay so yeah I don't know would you be
scared to take your shirt off yeah
really but you did but you well you and
your whole life like your whole life is
without you I know are you in your head
about it when you see yourself in a
movie uh like no movies always make you
look so good you look so much better on
camera than you oh my God you've got
like makeup on they do it like the right
lighting I like like uh Chris Pontius
and I just um recently made this video
um
10 times that we actually could have
died you know like the the 10 times
where like you know the closest we came
to actually dying and um it's all with
like crazy animals that can kill you
yeah and we designed this skateboard
where we're like skipping along arm and
arm like wearing like uh g-string
bikinis and there's a huge lion like
pouncing behind us yeah yeah and uh like
in order to
um you know to promote that several sign
the skateboards you sell them yeah and
uh and I want to make a video where
where we're actually wearing the
g-strings and skating you know like make
actual escape videos and I'm like pretty
self-conscious about getting in a bikini
right now really my body yeah a little
bit but oh so this is now not when
you're young right right now not when I
was younger when you're young but you
hit the scent you literally look the
same yeah
dude you look like you look he looks
you're uncomfortable about it yeah I
mean it's so crazy that you would that's
like the thing that's like the line he's
like dude you're like you're butt naked
all the time were you ever insecure
about being naked when you were when you
were younger I was very pretty easy with
being naked yeah yeah and maybe now you
guys are giving me confidence to go
skateboarding a g-string yeah dude yeah
I mean dude if I had your body I'd
[__] do you mind great oh thanks man
you look great like like it's if I'm
looking like you and I'm [__] what
are you 48 46 yeah dude you look like a
[__] stud so well thanks dude that's
crazy to to yeah no I don't I don't
think about that [__] are you thinking
about you you're thinking about a lot of
[__] like that
no just probably that yeah yours I can't
believe you're of all that like you're
insecure about that were you ever
insecure about when you were younger I
mean I think that what you're dealing
with with the three of us like we're all
um like heavily like messed up in the
head like addicts Vinnie used to live in
a [__] porta potty and shoot for two
years you had to go to prison for six
months and he went into prison with just
all kinds of [__] drugs in a
hypodermic needle up his ass that's
crazy my my uh it's my family it's
really crazy about my family
there's a lot of addicts in my face yeah
we're all server too so like we're all
like in 12-step recovery how long have
you guys been sober 10 years five years
15 years yeah I think my brother's like
15 now
um yeah but there's it's crazy there's a
lot of addicts in my family but it like
Miss I guess I'm gonna skip too I guess
I'm addicted to work and I I get very
like fixated on things but like not yeah
there's a lot of like gambling addicts
drug addicts the worst yeah yeah it's
it's hard yeah my family like has a lot
of that and like but everyone's cool now
unfortunately like uh my cousin he uh we
lost him to to drug a long time ago
um what drug uh his was his was math uh
but my my my brother
my brother did cracking heroin and but
he uh but he can he's [__] chilling
now he's like successful has just had a
kid like the best in the world like so
it's like most of the people in my
family have had like real good
turnaround stories that's why I don't do
drugs because I know like if I did I've
never even tried I've never even had
Coke in my life never done like drugs
like that no the only drugs I've ever
done is weed mushrooms and then I tried
Molly uh like a few times when I was a
kid
that's it yep and that's the thing is
that you know an addict an alcoholic can
get sober yeah but that doesn't make the
disease go away of course so like so
we're like and we're all pretty good at
being focused and do the right thing and
like we you know like alcoholism
addiction it's the only disease where
when you treat it you become a better
version of yourself than you were before
you know but
it comes with a price you know yeah we
all have great lives and but it comes
with a price because your your head is
just this
this God just doesn't stop oh dude it
doesn't it doesn't stop it doesn't stop
and it's your own mind just terrorizing
you with dude my brother gained a
hundred something pounds when he got
clean and I did too yeah yeah but now my
brother he dude he's like
down like over a hundred pounds yeah
like he got addicted like it just takes
that switch and then he got addicted to
like eating right and like working out
and like it took like 10 years but then
he like it just hit him and he was like
let's [__] go that's where I'm at now
you're now you're I'm on day five of
like no sugar now and now you're now
it's gonna be like a sick weird
Obsession and you'll be like 30 pounds
you're like your goal weights like 30
pounds but I probably want to be down to
185 but I'm at like 215 right now dude
you like look skin it's crazy like I
don't I don't see like you being like uh
it's weird but you never know when you
look at people yeah yeah yeah and you
get in your head everyone gets in their
head about stuff like we all get I get
in my head about certain things like
like do you ever get in your head about
your music and it's like oh it's not
good oh my God every time any time I
have like a number one song Something
huge the second I find out it's number
one I'm like [__] I'm doomed like this
my last one for sure like I'm always
there's a lot of imposter syndrome like
in in my career creative process like
creatively like there's that's where my
sh comes in because it's like like in
the same day I can be like I'm the best
and I can think I'm the best in the
world and also think like I'm the worst
because in my business so like
I'd say 95 of what I make in a year
never sees the light of day yeah so like
most of the sh I'm doing
is pointless like it's like completely
pointless I wish they were like March
23rd and I was like what March 23rd and
God was like yeah that's the only day
you're gonna do anything that means
anything this year and and to me it's
like uh
you know you're your own worst critic so
you're always putting down your music
yeah you're always like oh I'm not gonna
like I work with the biggest artist in
the [__] world and if you heard like
the type of like some of these artists
say like ones where you're like oh my
God their confidence must be through the
roof they're just like oh man
man it's good enough I'm not good enough
and these are the biggest people who
feel stadiums stadiums crazy and it's
like everybody has that like everybody
there's some part of your life where
like the confidence and like a lot of
times it's in like the work and it's
like yeah I'll I'll be sitting on like
something so good and I'll be like ah
it's not good enough it's not and I'll
fight with myself over it for so long
what number one hit did you have that
you thought was complete dog [__]
uh you're like there's no way and
they're like this is number one you're
like really no no I'll tell I'll tell
you what I'll tell you well some of
those I take my name off of
um and like I'm still number one yeah
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna bash anyone
but I will tell you I'll tell you a
story
so I was working with um you know who
Sia is okay so I was working with SIA
and her friend oh yeah actually saw you
at her place one time from a from a
distance yeah she's the best I've known
her for [__] like literally her first
pop session was with me in like 2007 or
807 or so yeah no after when she started
wanting to become a songwriter and we
became friends and then we wound up like
living at Jay-Z and Beyonce's house for
like for like months it was crazy uh and
uh so I'm working with her and these
producers called Stargate okay and
Stargate no they're like uh they're
music producers they did like every hit
in the [__] he's [__] sweating
back
yeah uh so so so this was before Uber
and we're sit at everyone's sitting
there and it's time to go and she call
see a call as a cab and she's like well
I have 14 minutes so like should I just
like do a little thing and then we made
a song uh it's called Diamonds by
Rihanna it was like a huge number one
hit and so she did does that whole thing
14 minutes under 14 minutes records it
writes it Melodies everything done and
then uh stargy was like I we want to
send this to Rihanna and I was like I
don't know man is this really the song
and they were like yeah and I'm like
really and then like they send it and
I'm and at the same time they we had
already sent it to Eminem and Kanye at
the time so it was like I was like why
don't one of them do it and uh we're
like going back and forth and I'm like I
really don't know and then uh this guy
named Tata made like a uh an adjustment
to it that made it sound better and
they're like Rihanna's cutting this and
I'm like okay I trust you I completely
trust you she cuts it she sends it back
it sounds like [__] amazing and then
it comes out and it's like a huge
[__] number one I had no idea at the
moment but then like sitting there like
that's why you gotta trust your
collaborators trust people around you
and then I'm like holy [__] this song
like I'm wrong and then sometimes you
think you have the biggest [__] song
in the world and nobody gives it you
know what I mean but like once you have
no control of anything yeah so it's like
once it's out you're just like doing it
my favorite Howard Stern music
song is when Sia does diamonds like her
just acapella dude she's she's [__]
incredible like it's very hard when you
do like demos to have someone else sing
her because it's so [__] good that
it's you're like hungry ever gonna beat
this demo because she's so incredible
and it's it's so cool that she can like
bounce back from like being an artist to
not you know her album her first album
that was like really huge as a solo
artist was just songs that people
rejected that was all and they and they
and then they became huge number ones
for her as an artists she was like I
think all these songs are pretty good so
she put him out herself as an artist and
then they were all numbers that's what
nobody knows you don't know anything
it's like when you made that video you
were like yo I think this video is going
to be the biggest thing in the world and
then it's not but then like something
you don't think is anything it's just an
afterthought become some huge thing and
that's why you gotta just like when
you're creative sometimes you gotta just
let go and put the [__] out yeah is that
a bathroom I gotta piss so bad yeah
let's wrap it up
dear Benny I love you I love you
I love you I have to pee so bad that
like I really think like you can't get
up yeah it's like scary you know when
it's like it's like in your back yeah
dude by the way we never go this long
man
I love it I love it man it's been it's
been an honor oh yeah and then this is
how we end we're done is that that's
just how it ends there's just no ending
it's just it's like the most
professional podcast I've ever been I
feel like yeah
you with me was he our favorite guest in
a long long time man what a treat now
there was a lot of profanity in that
episode you might have noticed that we
uh added some farting sounds it's just
because when there's super heavy
swearing
um we get dinged man like we get a
demonetized age restricted and it kills
the viewership and we can't kill the
viewership man we need this podcast to
go up so as always thank you for
watching to the end and let's give Benny
some love let's do our thing man let's
let's make the Wild Ride podcast just
triumphant and glorious yeah dude thanks
guys I love you